with conflicting emotions Palestinians
in Gaza are holding their breath waiting
for the Seas fire between Israel and
Hamas we have been displaced from our
homes in the northern Gaza City we don't
accept a 4-day truth this is nonsense we
want a full ceasefire we want to be able
to see our homes and bury our Dead 4
days are not enough some see it as a
victory for groups like
Hamas
when Israel started this war it had many
goals to eliminate the resistance and
free its captives but in the end it has
not succeeded in achieving them it has
relented to the resistance so this truce
is in the interest of the resistance
others wonder whether the reduction in
hostilities might mean they can return
to their homes but Israel says
Palestinians forced from northern Gaza
will not be allowed back for many
displaced families that is unfair and
unjust I left jabalia I've slept on the
floor for more than a month what law
justifies this the ceasefire allows some
people to safely retrieve their
belongings but for evacuees like us we
can't even go back to see if our homes
in the north are still standing or bury
our dead while the entire world
watches counting down to the Seas fire
Israel has intensified its attacks on
residential areas and refugee camps in
the Gaza
Strip Israeli forces bombarded homes and
refugee camps in Northern and Central
Gaza killing or injuring hundreds of
Palestinians in jabalia Gaza City der
balah and
arat even Khan Yunis in the South which
Israel says is safe came under
attack while the agreement offers a
glimmer of hope significant challenges
lie ahead ongoing attacks leave many
wondering whether the gunfire on their
streets will fall silent at all and they
know that Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has promised that any
pose in fighting will not mean the war
is
over as the world watches the fragile
ceasefire agreement unfold Palestinians
in Gaza are caught between hope and
skepticism and yearn for a lasting
solution to end the cycle of violence y
Al jazer kanun is in the sou Gaza
Strip make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer